it's gonna get wicked man out look I
think it's all gonna end up in WWE it's
all gonna end up in the ring doesn't it
feel like that a little bit well it does
because it's all a circus now but I feel
like now I'm probably saying that in
1960s
yeah you know they're probably probably
in the nineteen sixties when I would
Kennedy and Nixon that going this is a
debate on television yeah
it's just become a circus now that was
the first time there was a televised
debate
and then he saw that family they shot
that whole family Kennedys okay who's
they whoever did it man you know people
in Dallas but they shot Bobby too right
I did yeah they shot him yeah - I mean
if two of the brothers get gunned down
that's like the Earp's that doesn't
happen since the herbs I don't think
yeah they the Kennedys they're funny
Bunch they keep trying to do the one
thing that kills him yeah thank you guys
let's go back and do that occupation
that kills us so like like the two of
the brothers died and then the dad tries
to push the third son into it and like
he kills a bird in the river yes he
drives a car from the river and close
yeah I know I know her her son is a
comedian or her yeah her cousin is a
comedian that girl's cousin right so
this guy is it Ted is it Teddy or
whatever yet uh Teddy Torabi jr. no what
are we looking for the person who killed
someone yeah mark oh no it wasn't no it
was um yeah I think it was Ted Ted right
cert aid is a movie about it right but
Ted drives Clara for the bridge why he's
drunk into the river girl dies he gets
out of the car just assume she's dead
tenants she was living in there for like
12 hours or so facing the roof yeah
anyway so they're like oh you'll never
be president now Teddy it's like why the
[ __ ] he both of his brothers have been
already shot and killed at that point
like who the [ __ ] is going I'll do that
job dad like like it's sooner or later I
know you shouldn't give in to fear
shouldn't give in to it but sooner or
later the dad must have gone okay all
right like the dad buddy stage he was
like he was like a vegetable he's just
like getting run around with presidents
that's like [ __ ] you guys
he's probably giving his daughter a buzz
cut gonna send her
you think we'll have a lesbian president
in our lifetime or not um mm a lifetime
a hot one no no yeah I think you know I
don't think we'll have a hot lesbian in
charge of anything too busy making me do
chores for I mean to do anything like
that I'll just play bottom houses yeah
but I I do I think I well I think we'll
we have a gay president with him and I
thought I don't believe so I know we've
already got date we got a gay governor
in one state just got voted incorrect we
had a guy and a lot of these dudes are
being secretly gay and doing stuff Oh
everybody done something you're telling
me Mike Pence hasn't been in some prey
the guy listening a [ __ ] Amy Manning
or be oh she's painting some private guy
right thing you can just see it
allegedly I had a thing where I got beat
by two they have this these two have
this thing downtown these two Vietnamese
guys for 70 bucks would [ __ ] you up you
know they put you in this outfit and
these guys will [ __ ] you up and for 70
bucks it sounds like quite the bargain
why would you pay that because used to
stop you being gay no no this doesn't do
that I don't think I mean I didn't I
wasn't feeling just give me an erection
he'll be well that's what happened to me
one time came during it and I didn't
expect that and I and I've never been
gay I mean I you know like I had some
dude pay me like maybe 40 bucks to look
at his [ __ ] once when I was a kid but
that's not I don't know that's art
that's art but what happened Garba 40
bar yeah but but the thing was what I'm
saying was I didn't expect to get like a
feeling out of that that was kind of
that live and being up sexually mmm-hmm
you know like sometimes you don't know
where you're gonna get a feeling that's
gonna lie you really did you really
pulling my leg known up on your leg so
you paid to Eisenberg's to beat you up
Vietnamese yeah why well they would [ __ ]
you up and they put you in a suit and it
was kind of like uh what's this suit
I kind of have you ever seen a dog bite
suit pull up but a dog I like like okay
like assume it's right yeah but a nice
one not a sumo wrestle when that was
probably know though I know the one I'm
being chased down by a dog and one of
those outfits exactly like that when you
visit
there yeah these two guys would [ __ ]
start kicking you and beating you right
okay so what's the point of that to get
the feeling of it just made you feel
like a man made you feel like a it made
something come out of you that made you
feel it made me feel strong it made me
feel some pain it made me feel something
you know right and $650 for that suit
too so they had to get at least ten
before they made their money back in
that whole venture I have six ever
really the dry cleaning of the inside of
the city yeah good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one